gaffe était agrafé mois le patron alors
vous vous êtes ouvriers je suis comédien
est alors que là c'est comme un diamant
s'est tournée des comédiens c'est ça qui
a fait visiter mais déjà vu la télé ou
sur 5,8 mois justement je cherche un
sujet de reportage dans les petites
idées
ouais voilà vous êtes tombé juste le
café-théâtre losc hormis la superbe
siècle était bon sang mais c'est bien
sûr
oui un micro la tient à ce que vous
pouvez me présenter un petit peu alors
où est la troupe
là je vais vous présenter mes camarades
musiciens il ya christian clavier des
toilettes
michel blanc comédienne dit intel et
spécialement invité une équipe
concurrente des collègues
la veuve pichard cette affaire qui va
s'ouvrir à un peu plus loin
n'est ce pas oui c'est exact cette rue
sainte croix de la bretonnerie martin
lamotte christine danjou qui va nous
dire de dons c'est cette ré et jacques
delaporte musiciens et comédiens très
bien du splendid naturellement du
splendid nous avons nous avons la star
10 rue des lombards ici eux
marie-anne chazel je me suis coupé le
doigt cet affreux et mais ce pas le
grand le grand comment tu t'appelles tu
vois un tir il est remis pour la drees a
voulu dire chez elle le café-théâtre par
rapport au théâtre qu'est ce que c'est
disons que c'est un moyen de travailler
différemment et c'est moins cher et tout
le monde rigole beaucoup on écrit tout
complicité disons par rapport au théâtre
les gens sont plus près c'est un gros
plan par rapport au cinéma quoi le
théâtre c'est un plan général et le café
théâtre c'est un gros plan que je
devrais dire qu'on fait tous ici comment
vous êtes retrouvé est ce que vous êtes
tous des acteurs professionnels ou au
contraire c'est moi ce qu'il ya un
avenir dans le café théâtre à l'heure
actuelle je crois qu'il ya plus d'un an
dans le café théâtre actuellement dans
le théâtre proprement dit parce que les
quatre fermes et cafétérias trouve une
façon si si un fiasco on peut encore
être maçon là il ya aucun problème pour
l'instant vous êtes un petit peu en
chantier d'ailleurs on peut pas très
bien se rendre compte de ce que vous
faites est ce que vous pourriez vous
m'indiquer un endroit où je pourrai me
rendre
il y en a des bien mais vous avez une
enveloppe ah bon ah d'accord
à